[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que les bâlois ont
régné depuis depuis la guerre de cent
ans depuis depuis philippe si ce
qu'était un neveu du célèbre philippe le
bel alors il ya eu les valois capétiens
direct les valois à angoulême à la fin
la dynastie des valois au pouvoir en
france pendant la majeure partie de la
renaissance accéda au trône en 13 128
après la mort sans héritier du dernier
des rois capétiens charles iv le bel
philippe de valois son cousin de 20
alors roi sous le nom de philippe 6
certains historiens partagent les deux
cent soixante ans du règne des valois
selon trois phases la survie
les réalisations et la catastrophe
la survie fait référence à la guerre de
cent ans qui commence à quand un autre
cousin edouard iii d'angleterre se posa
en prétendant au trône de france est
remis en question la légitimité des
valois après avoir chassé les anglais
les rois valois achevèrent de rassembler
les provinces et préparer le terrain
pour le plus célèbre d'entre eux
françois 1er c'est lui à qui l'on doit
la réalisation d'oeuvres étonnante dans
le domaine de l'architecturé et des arts
et lettres ainsi que l'avènement de la
renaissance française la catastrophe
commence avec le fils de françois 1er
henri 2 dont la mort accidentelle en 15
100 59 marque le début des guerres de
religion
après avoir passé 26 ans dans l'ombre
l'épousé d'henri 2 l'italienne catherine
de médicis ont dos alors un rôle public
auprès de leurs trois fils et se
consacre à poursuivre l'oeuvre de son
mari
mais trente ans plus tard la lignée des
valois s'éteindra catherine de médicis a
un sens de la famille très fort elle
sera pour ces différents fils une mère
attentive
parfois un petit peu envahissante mais
très très attachées à l'exercice de leur
autorité
l'un après l'autre les trois frères
françois deux chars le neuf et henri iii
vont ceindre la couronne royale mais ils
seront parmi les monarques les plus
faibles que l'on n'ait jamais vu sur le
trône de france
en vérité on ne se souvient des derniers
des valois que par leur histoire
tragique et leur déclin
[Musique]
au printemps 15 159 le roi henri ii et
son épouse catherine de médicis semblent
prêts à entrer glorieusement dans la
postérité
leur fils aîné françois a épousé l'année
précédente
la vive et séduisante marie reine
decosse lors d'une magnifique cérémonie
ce qui permettrait à la france de faire
valoir un jour ses droits sur le trône
d'angleterre
à présent le couple royal prévoit les
somptueuses festivités qui auront lieu
pour le mariage de leur fille elisabeth
de valois la france a mené une guerre
pour s'approprier les territoires
détenus traditionnellement par les
habsbourg d'espagne et d'autriche
henri ii et philippe ii d'espagne sont
des ennemis mortels comme leur père
l'était avant que le père de philippe ii
était charles quint empereur du saint
empire romain germanique qui dirigea le
royaume le plus puissant et le plus
étendu de toute l'europe jusqu'à son
abdication en faveur de son fils
françois 1er père d'henri deux s'étaient
mis en travers des ambitions de
l'empereur habsburg tout au long de son
règne à court d'argent est préoccupée
par la propagation du protestantisme
henri de france et philippe d'espagne se
voit contraint à faire la paix en 15 100
elle met fin à une rivalité de plus de
40 ans entre les deux familles la paix
scellée par le mariage d'elizabeth de
valois avec philippe ii d'espagne
ces mariages royaux semble annoncer une
nouvelle ère de stabilité et de
prospérité
henri ii est un colosse
bel homme rompu à tous les exercices
physiques il tient beaucoup de françois
1er son père et henry 2 ème beaucoup
l'un des camps sports des gens de sa
catégorie j'allais dire c'est à dire des
rois des princes de la grande noblesse
qu'elle est tournoi se substitue delà de
la guerre
pour célébrer l'événement on rit
organise durant l'été un tournoi de
trois jours à l'hôtel des tournelles
contre l'avis de ses ministres il
participe lui même aux joues le
troisième jour là lance de bois de son
jeune adversaire transpercé le home du
roi se casse qui s'enfonce dans son
deuil
le roi reste pendant onze jours entre la
vie et la mort mais bientôt l'infection
gagne et il meurt le 10 juillet 15 159
quand henry demeure à la suite de ce
tournoi tout à fait contrariant eh bien
il ya toute une tribu d'héritier qui
sont capables de régner on est
tranquille on a au moins quatre fils
donc la couronne est assuré on en est
convaincu
on a d'abord le petit françois 2 le
futur petit françois ii ensuite on va
avoir le char le neuf qui arrivera après
françois 2 et henri 3000 y en avait
encore un autre qui va encore hercule le
duc d'alençon donc quatre fils ont été
sauvées ans ridley son épouse catherine
de médicis en charge d'un très jeune roi
et de quatre enfants au sein d'un
royaume en faillite est divisée de plus
deux autres familles puissantes se pose
en rival pour le contrôle du trône les
bourbons et l'église la famille de
bourbon compte parmi les siens antoine
de bourbon
premier prince du sang et roi de navarre
par son épouse ainsi que ses jeunes
frères le cardinal charles de bourbon et
le prince louis de condé
lorsqu'à roy était trop jeune pour
régner il était de coutume que le
premier prince de sang assure la régence
mais cela cause un certain émoi dans la
population catholique car antoine de
bourbon et le prince de condé sont des
adeptes de la nouvelle religion l'église
famille de nobles puissant et ambitieux
ont à leur tête le duc de guise
ce sont de fervents catholiques
bien que leur maison de lorraine ne
puisse revendiquer aucune ligne royale
ils comptent parmi eux une reine decosse
leur soeur mary 2 ghz
ayant épousé jacques 5 décosse ainsi
qu'une reine de france lors nièce marie
stuart les protestants pense que les
bourbons vont assurer la régence et
qu'ils installeront ensuite en france la
liberté religieuse mais durant les
heures qui précèdent la mort du roi le
duc de guise et son frère le cardinal de
lorraine met au point une stratégie pour
empêcher les bourbons d' assurer la
régence et prendre leur place
[Musique]
sept des enfants d'henri ii et de
catherine de médicis ont survécu et 3
sont déjà mariés au moment de l'accident
qui a coûté la vie au roi le dauphin et
héritier du trône françois a épousé son
ami d'enfance marie stuart reine decosse
qui deviendra l'une des figures les plus
tragiques de l'histoire britannique
elle est la fille de jacques 5 décosse
et de mary 2 ghz la famille de guise le
rennes a su faire son chemin à la cour
et s'approcher du pouvoir après le
mariage de françois catherine ne
concerne guère d'influencé sur son fils
alors âgé de 15 ans alors quand on
décide de donner au petit françois ii au
futur petit françois 2 comme épouse
marie magritte des causses marie stuart
et bien quand on s'appelle catherine de
médicis on a une arrière-pensée derrière
la tête
pourquoi parce que la petite reine marie
avait pour maman une guise donc en
faisant entrer l'église dans le
gouvernement
elle se protéger parce qu elle l'adorait
l'église les catholiques bien entendu
françois a reçu le nom de son célèbre
grand-père mais il est de constitution
fragile car une série d'infections a
retardé sa croissance
le dauphin partage la passion familiale
pour la chasse et se lance en modération
dans cette activité violente
en revanche son état de santé ne lui
permet pas de réaliser son désir
d'égaler son père
louis le quatrième enfant d'henry est
mort en bas âge charles le cinquième est
également de faible constitution est
sujet à des crises nerveuses
bien que vive d'esprit ils ne montrent
aucune aptitude pour les études
catherine de médicis ne l'aiment pas
elle réserve son affection pour son
sixième enfant
edouard alexandre qui deviendra henry à
l'âge de 13 ans et demi
prénom qui convient mieux à un héritier
présomptif du trône de france henri donc
et le plus brillant et le plus robuste
le seul à n'avoir aucun problème de
santé en lui
les medicis commencent à apparaître et à
se mêler aux meilleurs des valois
catherine ne cache pas sa préférence et
lui vous en retour une dévotion et une
obéissance totale
catherine de médicis depuis l'avènement
de charles 9 jouent ce jeu de bascule
entre l'église et le parti protestant
lorsqu elles inclinent du côté du parti
protestant
elle met tout son poids dans la balance
pour conclure un mariage très politique
entre l'un des princes du parti
protestant qui s'appelle henri de
navarre le futur henri iv et l'une de
ses filles marguerite celle qu'on
appellera plus tard la reine margot
marguerite dit margot et la 7e des
enfants elle possède de nombreuses
qualités
la beauté l'amabilité le charme bien
qu'elle et son frère henri manifestent
le même attachement envers leur mère
catherine de médicis n'a d'yeux que pour
son fils et se montre très sévère envers
marguerittes
en réaction marguerite chercheurs à
l'amour partout où elle pourra le
trouver
le plus jeune des valois et hercules
françois appelé plus tard françois
il a été défigurée par la variole quand
il était tout petit et ans son quatrième
fils il reçoit très peu d'attention de
la part de sa mère katherine d'un enfin
naissance à des jumeaux en 15/100 56
mais là meurent à la naissance et le
second un mois plus tard pendant
qu'henri 7,1 à l'hôtel des tournelles
catherine de médicis rassemble ses
enfants et s'enfuit a vécu dans le
carrosse royal elle rejoint le louvre
avec la famille de guise à ses trousses
leur neveu françois et ans l'héritier du
trône l'église prenne le contrôle de la
couronne
étonnamment antoine de bourbon ne s'y
opposent pas ils arrivent en retard et
s'avère facile à manipuler la mauvaise
constitution du jeune roi ainsi que sa
faible intelligence font de lui un
simple instrument aux mains des guises
françois ii est couronné en septembre
dans la cathédrale de reims lors de la
cérémonie que fragile monarque est
accablé par le poids de la couronne un
présage des événements à venir
les nouveaux souverain de france
françois ii et mary stuart ont grandi
ensemble à la cour où la fillette avait
été envoyé dès l'âge de 6 ans si marie a
un goût pour les études
ce n'est pas le cas de françois on dit
surtout qu'il n'est pas doué et
intellectuellement
malgré son aspect chétif il préfère la
chasse l'équitation et le tir à l'arc
françois qui idolâtrent est son père est
très affectée par sa mort il se console
en s'adonnant à des exercices violent
pour un valois chasser est le seul
remède contre les vicissitudes de la vie
il consacre les six premiers mois à la
chasse puis les forces lui manque et il
tombe gravement malade il se plaint d'un
abcès à l'oreille catherine consultent
pour lui plusieurs médecins à
fontainebleau
il lui recommande de passer l'hiver à
blois tout en sachant qu'il ne lui reste
que peu de temps à vivre
la soumission des bourbons la famille de
guise est un mauvais coup porté à la
cause protestante
on craint que les tensions religieuses
qui couvait sous le règne d'henri 2
nomen bientôt à la guerre civile
le duc de guise a été nommé lieutenant
général du royaume
mais ses convictions catholiques sont
momentanément maîtrisé par le chancelier
de france michel de l'hôpital qui est
protestant l'exclusivité dont bénéficie
l'église et leurs procédés désinvolte et
veille le ressentiment des princes du
sang
c'est d'abord le firent prince de condé
de la famille des bourbons qui manifeste
son opposition au pouvoir déguisent
il est suivi par son frère le chant jean
antoine de bourbon roi de navarre comme
les bourbons de nombreux noble se sont
exclus du pouvoir et rejoignent les
protestants les persécutions initiée par
envie de se poursuivre avec la même
rigueur et les protestants ne savent
plus quoi faire alors l'enlèvement de
françois ii est prévu par les bourbon
condé à amboise c'est ce qu'on appelle
le tumulte d'amboise organisé par par un
homme de main qui s'appelle la renaudie
il y aura à la suite de ça il y aura
quelque chose comme 15 cents morts on
imagine le château d'amboise gorgé de
cadavres suspendus aux murailles
larnaudie est en coupe et en différents
morceaux en cinq ou six morceaux qu'on a
essaimé dans toute la ville d'amboise
pour bien montrer que qu'il était
vraiment fautif d'avoir tenté cet
enlèvement du roi et à partir de ce
moment là évidemment les protestants qui
ont été sévèrement châtiés sévèrement
punis vont se transformer non plus en en
partis religieux mais en faction en
parti politique
la cour doit quitter amboise pour
chenonceau où ont lieu les dernières
exécutions 56 victimes s'avance tour à
tour tandis que courtisans et notables y
compris le roi sa mère sa femme si
petits frères et soeurs sont forcée
d'assister aux châtiments atroce les
prédictions de catherine se réalise
ces exécutions brutales n'ont fait
qu'attiser la colère
le peuple s'élèvent contre ce qu'ils
estiment être un gouvernement illégitime
l'église devienne l'objet d'une haine
fanatique qui se propage dans tout le
pays
une fois ce complot achevé l'église
paraissent tout puissant ils peuvent
même envisagé un temps de faire exécuter
le prince de condé ce qui n'arrivera pas
mais les cadres être très très vite
rebattues car cette situation qui est
celle de l'automne qu'un 159 est
complètement remodelé à la mort de
françois 2 dans l'hiver qu'un 159 460
qui voit effectivement la disgrâce
sensible des 10 et le retour au pouvoir
autour du petit roi charles neuf qui la
lui est mineur effectivement il a passé
13 ans révolus donc il est en situation
de minorité d'un groupe constitué de la
reine mère katherine de nouveaux
personnages compter des personnages
importants sous le règne de henri ii le
maréchal de s'entendre et le connétable
de montmorency et antoine de bourbon
le prince roi de navarre au roi d'une
partie de la navarre et qui est un
prince de la famille royale la princesse
du sang c'est autour de ces gens là que
le pouvoir de nouveau certes éculés le
duc de guise est en disgrâce
catherine étend son influence l'exercice
du pouvoir la fait revivre et la pousse
à parfaire son rôle de femme d'état
en s'inspirant de l'héritage de son mari
elle essaie de restreindre le pouvoir
déguise et d'instaurer un compromis
entre les catholiques et les huguenots
qu'on appelle en france les calvinistes
les bobos sont traités de rebelles quand
l'information d'une nouvelle
conspiration parvient aux oreilles du
roi catherine cherche encore à
réconcilier les deux camps afin de
stabiliser l'état
elle écrit à plusieurs reprises à
antoine de bourbon et au prince de condé
elle leur demande de revenir à la cour
et leur garantit la sécurité françois 2
à tout autre chose en tête dès que les
bourbons arrive à la cour
ils arrêtent le prince de condé qui est
condamné à mort mais les délibérations
sont suspendues car le roi souffre d'une
autre infection à l'oreille le sort de
condé est désormais lié à celui du roi
la santé de françois se dégrade de plus
en plus en décembre l'église sens le
pouvoir leur échapper et les bourbons
eux sont qu'il s'en approche à grands
pas mais catherine entre de nouveau dans
la partie à la mort de son mari elle
n'avait pas eu la force d'agir tant elle
était ravagé par le chagrin
cette fois elle est prête encouragé par
son frère antoine de bourbon affronte
catherine de médicis mais il n'est pas
de taille face à cette redoutable
négociatrice catherine convainc antoine
de se ranger du côté des catholiques
une fois de plus il renonce à son droit
légitime à la régence
après avoir réfléchi il écrira dans son
journal le 5 décembre 15 160 qu'il avait
troqué son droit de naissance contre une
bouchée de pain
l'infection du roi se transforme en
abcès au cerveau et il meurt la même
nuit elle et régente les
et régente pour le compte du deuxième
fils qu'elle a eu avec henri ii pas
régné sous le nom de charles neuf et
elle va commencer un jeu de bascule un
jeu qui va consister à essayer
d'équilibrer le rôle déguise en
s'alliant chaque fois que l'occasion se
présente avec des chefs du parti
protestante
[Musique]
c'est charles maximilien alors âgée de
10 ans qui succède à son frère il est
sacré en la cathédrale de reims le 15
mai 15 161 et devient charles neuf de
france
la région s'est confiée à sa mère
jusqu'à sa majorité
catherine de médicis supervise chaque
détail de sa vie et le fait dormir dans
la même chambre qu'elle charles est un
garçon mince guère plus robuste que
françois de constitution frêle il
s'énerve très vite comme son frère aîné
il est passionné par la chasse mais ne
peut s'y adonner comme il le voudrait en
raison de sa santé sa mère quand elle
fait montre d'une volonté infatigable
elle emploie toute sa force et son art
de la ruse pour remettre sur pied les
finances du pays et résoudre la question
religieuse tout en évitant que les
puissances étrangères s'en mêle pourtant
le règne de charles neuf va être marquée
par les guerres de religion qui comme on
le craignait éclate finalement en 15 162
plongeant les deux camps dans la
violence les huguenots bénéficie d'un
soutien considérable dans la noblesse
tandis que leurs ennemis qui formeront
plus tard la puissante ligue catholique
ou sainte ligue sont menés par la maison
de guise
catherine et charles évite de prendre
parti trop ouvertement les guerres de
religions vont opposer un parti
protestant à la monarchie massivement
soutenu par les catholiques
ça c'est le cas de figure qui va durer
pendant disons les dix bonnes premières
années ensuite à partir du milieu des
années quatre cent soixante dix la
situation va se compliquer par
l'apparition d'un parti catholique
favorable à des réformes politiques et
qui peut dans certains cas s'allier avec
des protestants contre la monarchie
ce qu'on appelle les mâles comptant dans
les années qu'un cent soixante dix pour
porter un programme de réformes c'est
pas des anti monarchistes du tout et ils
sont pas protestants ils sont bien
catholique mais ils sont prêts dans
certaines circonstances à s'allier avec
des hérétiques pour obtenir des réformes
du royaume au cours de la première
guerre de religion trois personnages
essentiels disparaissent
antoine de bourbon qui se bat du côté
catholique et mortellement blessée au
siège de roi le duc de guise chef du
parti catholique est assassiné durant le
siège d'orléans et le chef des
protestants le prince de condé frère
d'antoine de bourbon se rendent durant
la bataille de jarnac et est assassiné
par un capitaine des gardes du duc
d'anjou dans les années 15 170 c'est la
génération suivante qui entre dans le
conflit le nouveau duc de guise henry
poursuit la cause de son père et le fils
d'antoine de bourbon henri de bourbon
prince de navarre assume courageusement
le rôle de chef des protestants à la
suite de son oncle le prince de condé
le pays jouit d'une paix temporaire
charles le neuf alors âgé de 20 ans
épouse elisabeth d'autriche charlet de
caractère instable
en grandissant il s'est mis à détester
sa mère ainsi que son fils préféré le
jeune henry
catherine a encore suffisamment
d'ascendant sur lui malgré leurs
sentiments qu'ils éprouvent envers elle
jusqu'au moment où il rencontre une
figure paternelle en la personne du
héros de la réforme le chef des
protestants l'amiral gaspard de coligny
il est difficile de dire ce qui pousse
charles du côté des protestants ils
commencent à se rendre compte que les
objectifs des catholiques ne sont pas
toujours dans l'intérêt de la france
il résiste à l'emprise de sa mère il est
jaloux de son frère plus robuste et se
méfient déguisent
selon certaines rumeurs l'espagne
catholique assisté par la maison 2 ghz
chercherait à affaiblir la france pour
que charles cède au roi philippe les
tensions s'exacerbent les jeunes frères
du roi et leurs alliés le nouveau duc de
guise sont opposés à l' influence de
l'amiral de coligny charles neuf incline
à une véritable alliance militaire avec
les protestants le chef militaire des
protestants et temps l'amiral de coligny
le chef
on peut dire du point de vue du prestige
du point de vue de la relation avec la
famille royale c'est henri de navarre
mais le chef militaire c'est l'amiral de
coligny le 18 août a lieu un mariage
royal le fils d'antoine henri de bourbon
se marie avec sa cousine la jolie
marguerite de valois dernière fille
d'henri ii et de catherine de médicis
henry et protestants et il est le
nouveau premier prince du sang cette
alliance est l'ultime tentative de
catherine pour réunir les deux parties
et installer la paix
le mariage royal d'un huguenots et d'une
catholique doit mettre un terme aux
dissensions et raffermir la situation du
pays
alors le mariage d'henri de navarre et
de la petite margaux la future reine
margot la fille de catherine de médicis
est prévue donc on a prévu de le
célébrer à paris a priori ça s'annonce
bien puisque tous les big lots sont
venus accompagner leurs chefs le
le jeune a envie et on se prépare de
grandes réjouissances mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que catherine de médicis
l'on surnomme là serpente dans
l'histoire catherine de médicis à une
arrière pensée une arrière pensée dans
le crâne elle envisage manifestement de
venir à bout les protestants le pape
n'est pas d'accord il ne donne pas son
autorisation à ce mariage
alors on ment un peu au cardinal
archevêque on lui dit bah l'autorisation
du pape est parti de rome elle n'est pas
encore arrivée et catherine de médicis y
tient elle dit c'est on va on va ligoté
les protestants par ce mariage
la cérémonie se déroule sur une grande
estrade placé à la porte ouest de notre
dame marguerite n'a accepté cette
alliance que sous la pression de son
frère on dit que lorsque le moment fut
venu de donner son consentement
elle hésita si longtemps que le roi se
leva et lui et enfance à la tête dans le
coussin placé devant elle si bien que le
cardinal pris cela pour un acquiescement
la cérémonie annonce un mariage
tumultueux et l'ambiance à paris laisse
mal augurer de l'avenir des milliers de
protestants sont venus des campagnes
vers la ville pour le mariage et ont
commencé à se mêler aux catholiques la
ville bruisse de mécontentement et l'on
entend d incitation au meurtre prononcer
à voix basse
la vague de chaleur qui s'abat sur paris
est ressenti comme un nouveau présage
par une cité déjà au bord de la révolte
il six jours plus tard l'enfer va
s'abattre sur paris et restera dans les
mémoires horrifié comme le massacre de
la saint barthélemy
le massacre qui suit le mariage semble
plonger ses racines dans le fanatisme
religieux
mais en fait c'est d'abord un acte
politique catherine de médicis et le duc
de guise ont décidé que gaspard de
coligny devait disparaître le chef des
huguenots a trop d' influence sur le roi
charles neuf dont il est le conseiller
le 22 août à l'insu du roi collini est
victime d'une tentative d'assassinât
on lui tire dessus tandis qu'il marche
dans les rues de paris
les balles lui emporte un doigt de la
main droite et fracasse son coût de
gauche charles neuf se précipite à son
chevet et jure de retrouver ses
assassins et de les punir
craignant de violentes représailles
catherine de médicis aiguise doivent
trouver le moyen de brouiller les pistes
il décide alors d'assassiner tous les
chefs protestant de paris comme on
cacherait une aiguille dans une meule de
foin
ils pensent dissimulé l'attentât contre
collini parmi d'autres mais comment
convaincre charles d'en donner l'ordre
dans la nuit du 24 août pressé par sa
mère et son frère henri charles accepte
de dire que coligny se sert de lui qu'il
a l'intention de renverser tout la cour
catholique et qu'il doit donc ainsi que
tous les chefs nos être éliminé à titre
préventif la peur et la colère
déclenchée charles une crise de folie
son entourage parvient à le plonger dans
le doute il tombe dans un accès de
violence paranoïa qui le fait c'est
crier ainsi que leur apportera dans son
journal son frère henry et bien tué
l'amiral soit mais qu'on les tue tous
pour qu'ils ne restent pas un pour me le
reprocher ses paroles déclenché le
processus parfaitement orchestré destiné
à débarrasser paris de toute opposition
les gardes suisses postés à l'extérieur
de la chambre de collines y sont
facilement a battu la mire à les tuer
puis jetée par une fenêtre en bas de
laquelle attend le duc de guise qui
veulent achever lui même puis il donne
le signal convenu
les cloches du beffroi de saint germain
l'auxerrois commencé à sonner le glas
toute volée enfermée à double tour les
portes de la ville et soudain les
troupes catholique se jette dans la
tuerie ils vont exterminer tous les chu
que tout a dérapé et il ya une sorte de
folie insurrectionnel révolutionnaire
dirons-nous qui a consisté dans les rues
de paris a tué tous protestants au
louvre a tué tous protestant à dans la
seine ont jeté des corps et puis après
mais qui se noyait pas assez vite on les
retire et avec une pique wind lançant
les poignarder on leur mettait en scène
des pillages et des combats éclatent
dans tout paris plus de 2000 hommes
femmes et enfants sont abattues ou
blessé à mort parmi eux beaucoup n'ont
rien à voir dans les querelles
politiques ou religieuses on se demande
toujours si l'ampleur du carnage était
le projet de catherine de médicis celui
du duc de guise ou si les meurtres
prirent un tour aveugle car personne ne
maîtrisait plus la situation
le sang va couler pendant des jours la
scène charrie des foules de cadavres des
massacres du même type ont ensuite lieu
dans les provinces les catholiques en
profitant pour se débarrasser de leurs
rivaux huguenots à rome le pape fait
chanter un télécoms les frapper des
médailles commémoratives cependant que
de nombreux catholiques modérés
dégoûté par cette boucherie se
détournent de l'église romaine pour
aller vers le protestantisme paris viii
le moment le plus sombre de son histoire
et la dynastie des valois ne s'en
remettra jamais l'europe entière est
sous le choc et en priorité la cour
d'espagne et la cour de rome
les deux grandes tours catholiques
celles qui pèsent le plus lourd sans
doute à ce moment là le pape d'un côté
et le roi d'espagne l'autre se
réjouissent absolument de cette
opération dont il faut bien voir qu'elle
est conçue par eux et en partie parce
qu'ils l'ont mise en oeuvre comme une
purification du royaume de france d'un
royaume qui est pollué par une saumure
religieuse fondamentale et on ne peut
pas s'attendre à leurs yeux
nous en pensions aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas s'attendre à leurs yeux à ce que la
la colère de dieu se retire du royaume
de france
tant que cette pollution et j'emploie le
mot à dessein il est employé à l'époque
un temps que cette pollution ne sera pas
nettoyé le massacre des clans une
quatrième guerre civile qui s'achève au
moment où henri duc d'anjou était le roi
de pologne
à l'initiative de sa mère en mai 15 173
durant l'été catherine organise deux
somptueux divertissement en l'honneur
des ambassadeurs polonais venu rendre
visite à la cour de france et ramener le
roi en pologne
[Musique]
catherine de médicis qui adore le petit
henri son duc d'anjou veut quand même
qu'il soit efficace et qu'il fasse
quelque chose
or le trône de pologne qui est une
monarchie élective
c'est à dire que on n'hérite pas de la
couronne en pologne on est élu roi de
pologne et bien et libre est vacant à ce
moment-là et henri iii le futur henri
iii henri se fait élire watts pologne
sous le nom de henri malaisie de sadir
valois levallois et il va s'installer en
pologne où il n'y restera pas longtemps
d'ailleurs
mais le temps qu'ils y restent catherine
est satisfait parce que la pologne est
catholique c'est un petit peu un étau
qui se fait entre les deux pays
catholique que sont la france la pologne
sur l'allemagne qui a une tendance
protestante est évidente
catherine de médicis et la première
dirigeante a organisé ces fêtes royales
avec balla thème bankable est
d'inspiration italienne divertissement
qui feront plus tard la renommée des
monarques français ces bals fastueux
servent un objectif politique
c'est pourquoi elle estime pouvoir y
consacrer des sommes colossales pour
contrer l'image d'une monarchie sur le
déclin la reine mère veut montrer au
peuple français ainsi qu'aux cours
étrangères que les bâlois sont aussi
puissants et magnifique que durant les
règnes de françois 1er et d'henri 2 son
époux
[Musique]
l'élection du duc d'anjou à la tête d'un
royaume étrangers et peut-être une
erreur car son éloignement divise la
famille et fortifie les ambitions
politiques de son cadet françois ducs
d'alençon
il se rebelle contre catherine de
médicis rêve de ceindre la couronne et
même d'épouser la reine elizabeth
d'angleterre
enfin il met en place le complot des
mâles content il est arrêté et demeura
retenue à la cour sous surveillance
cependant la santé de charles décline
après le massacre de la saint barthélemy
il est hanté par le souvenir des
protestants assassiné à sa nourrice
huningue note qui se tient à son chevet
il confie ses remords il lui dit qu'il
n'aurait jamais ordonné ces meurtres
s'il n'avait pas cru comme on le lui
souffler que les siens lui même était en
danger
durant les deux années suivantes il se
vengera contre sa mère en gardant le
silence en par de brusques accès de
colère
épuisée par de longues journées de
chasse lui qui n'avait jamais été bien
robuste fini par s'éteindre usés
physiquement et moralement il n'a plus
la volonté de vivre et meurt à 24 heures
de la tuberculose le 30 mai 15 174 au
château de vincennes
catherine de médicis le coeur brisé et
de nouveau en charge du pouvoir
elle envoie immédiatement en pologne un
messager elle demande à son fils préféré
de revenir au plus vite pour monter à
son tour sur le trône de france
il est en âge de gouverner est en pleine
possession de ses moyens physiques et
intellectuelles elle sait qu'il aura
encore besoin de son aide et de son
expérience
mais elle se réjouit de pouvoir se
libérer d'un fardeau qui commence à lui
peser
à la mort de charles neuf catherine de
médicis n'a qu'une hâte c'est d'envoyer
des émissaires en pologne pour dire à
son petit chéri à henry ça y est le
trône est libre il faut que tu viennes
le récupérer henry avait à peine de
commencer de gouverner formal new york
parce que la pologne ne l'intéressait
pas il quitte la pologne avec ses amis
qui d'ailleurs confisqué tout l'argent
qui a dans les caisses de la pologne
ils descendent vers vers venise où il va
rester pendant six mois avant de venir
hérité le trône de france et c'est un
personnage complètement modifié après
son séjour à venise ce n'est plus le
henric le conte est ce que l'on
connaissait auparavant il comment
dirais-je il est devenu il est rentré
très efféminé henri iii charles le neuf
est mort trois mois après le
couronnement d'henry en pologne
ce dernier fuit son royaume en cachette
le 18 juin 15 174
il abandonne la ces sujets pour
retrouver le trône dont il est
l'héritier henri iii est couronné en
février 15 175 et la même année il
épouse louise de lorraine dont il n'aura
pas d'enfants
le climat de la cour change complètement
il reflète la personnalité du nouveau
monarque
bien que très intelligent enrico mais
toutes les erreurs que ne doit pas faire
un bon politique le plus offensant aux
yeux du monde et le désintérêt du roi
pour la chasse ses centres d'intérêt ont
un caractère plus féminins comme la mode
et les bijoux
cela suffirait à dresser la france
contre lui mais de plus un moment il
faut que le souverain renoue avec son
peuple en riz malgré les avis de sa mère
s'isole et tente de renforcer son
autorité en instaurant une distance
physique entre lui et ses sujets et en
établissant à la cour une étiquette très
strictes la fameuse étiquette de la cour
une étiquette dans laquelle tous les
noms sont d'ailleurs au féminin
qu'auront start c'est sa majesté son
éminent son altesse tout est au féminin
parce que cette étiquette voulait que le
matin on le lait vont le poudre ont le
coup à fond
on lui met des petits lacets sur son
corsage etc etc il s'aliène de nombreux
courtisans en accordant ses faveurs qui
a quelques élus les fameux mignon c'est
une relation extrêmement forte c'est une
relation d'amitié extrêmement forte mais
qui n'a pas la connotation que bien sûr
lui donneront à certains de ses
adversaires dans des pamphlets des son
temps de books d'homosexuels en
resterait pour du toit roux efféminé ça
a été un grands combattants des guerres
de religion y compris d'ailleurs sous
son règne le règne de son frère charles
à neuf il a combattu au hasard mais bien
plus directement que charles à neuf il
s'est battu à de nombreuses reprises et
il n'a rien d'un efféminé
incontestablement à cette époque
catherine de médicis et du côté de la
famille de guise
elle approuve la création de la ligue
catholique mais henry 2 est moins facile
à manipuler que charles et devient de
plus en plus hostiles au guide en 15 100
84 son frère et unique héritier moeurs
leur cousin henri de bourbon devient le
premier dans la succession au trône
les forces catholiques prennent des
mesures pour l'empêcher de devenir roi
en 15288 le duc de guise considéré alors
comme un héros revient à paris malgré
l'interdiction qui lui en a été faite et
soulève le peuple contre le roi c'est ce
qu'on appelle la journée des barricades
henri iii tentent de s'opposer au duc
mais ces soldats sont vaincus et il doit
s'enfuir de paris pour gagner saint
cloud et se réfugier finalement à blois
henry ne parvient pas à décider d'un
plan d'action
ils se montrent indécis et réactionnaire
en juillet il accède à la demande du duc
de guise et signe les dit d'union par
lequel ils s'engagent à ne jamais faire
la paix avec les hérétiques
mais en vérité il ne cherche qu'à
prendre sa revanche
impuissant le roi refuse de rentrer à
paris tant que ghz est au pouvoir il
convoque les états généraux à blois en
retour le duc le contraint à signer un
décret interdisant le protestantisme et
empêchant l'accès des bourbons au trône
au cours des mois précédents l'hiver les
tensions s'accroissent entre les deux
hommes
le duc de guise est alerté par des
rumeurs d'assassinats il menace le roi
de lui livrer une guerre sans merci
tôt le matin du 23 décembre ghz et son
frère se rend à une réunion du conseil
royal qui se tient à blois le duc
remarque dans la cour du château et sur
les marches du célèbre escalier
renaissance construit par françois 1er
un nombre inhabituel de gardes royaux
quand il arrive dans la chambre du
conseil
on informe guise que le souverain
désirent le voir dans un salon privé
attenant à la chambre royale
c'est là que les gardes du roi
l'assassinent henri iii pose le pied sur
la tête du duc en signe de victoire
et pour s'assurer qu'aucun prétendant au
trône ne puisse agir contre lui il fait
assassiner son frère le cardinal de
guise est emprisonné son fils cet
assassinat provoque le soulèvement
immédiat de la ligue
très peu de temps après le parlement
l'accuse de crimes et le peuple
excommunie pour le meurtre du cardinal
les conséquences vont être dramatiques
tous ceux qui ont pu croire que le roi
et la ligue s'entendait durablement
vont immédiatement nombreux parmi eux
vont se tourner contre le roi henri iii
a beau dire mais le programme de la
ligue je continue à le faire
j'élimine et le duc quelqu'un d'érudit
ce parce qu'ils étaient une menace
contre mon pouvoir
pas du tout pour des raisons religieuses
il a beau affirmer cela ce n'est pas
demi est très très vite dès le mois de
juin deux mois de janvier 489 toute une
série de groupes de communauté
d'individus de prince vont rompre leur
allégeance envers le roi ça va aller
très très loin la faculté de théologie
de l'université de paris la sorbonne va
délier les sujets du roi de france de
leur serment d'allégeance donc à
véritablement une rupture au plus
profond de ce qui lie politiquement et
religieusement les deux sont
indissociables
leprince et ses sujets contrairement à
ses enfants
catherine est doté d'une santé de fer et
d'une grande force des récupérations
la nouvelle de la mort du duc l'anéantît
car elle lui révèle son échec le fiscal
idolâtré celui à qui elle a consacré sa
vie à briser tout ce qu'elle a construit
et rejeter tout ce qu'elle lui a appris
elle a perdu tout espoir de victoire
pour le seul de ses fils qui soit encore
en vie
elle est trop vieille trop malade et
trop fatigué pour se battre encore en
moins de deux semaines le 5 janvier 15
189 la grande matriarche qui a donné
naissance à trois roi meurt
henri iii va finir par s'allier à henri
de navarre contre l'église qui tiennent
paris et ensemble en 1589
ils vont assiéger paris siège de paris
qui sera levé quant à henri iii va être
assassiné par un moine à saint cloud où
il a établi son quartier général
catherine avait raison
le premier round 15189 henri iii poster
avec l'armée royale au château de
saint-cloud prépare une offensive pour
reprendre paris quand un jeune
dominicain fanatiques jacques clément
est autorisé à lui remettre des
documents importants
lemoine lui donne une liasse de papiers
et déclare qu'il a un message secret à
lui délivrer henry se penche vers lui et
clément lui plonge un couteau dans
l'abdomen avec la mort d'henri iii
s'achève la dynastie des valois
trois frères de la famille des valois
françois 2 charles neuf et henri iii
sont montés sur le trône
ils ont traversé la période sombre des
guerres de religion vécue le massacre de
la saint-barthélemy vu la création de la
ligue catholique et ont été mêlés aux
combats déguise pour usurper la place
des bourbons les princes du sang
d'autre part catherine de médicis à
assurer la régence auprès de ses trois
fils et fait tout ce qui était en son
pouvoir pour affermir leurs positions
mais tous ces efforts et ces calculs
n'ont abouti qu'à une victoire à court
terme sans elle n'a pu empêcher que
s'accomplisse leur destin henry 2 comme
son père françois 1er n'a pas eu le
courage de se proclamer chef de l'église
gallicane ce qui aurait permis aux
différentes religions de coexister mais
il était possible de le faire après sa
mort si son fils aîné françois deux on
avait eu le courage la france aurait pu
échapper à ces décennies de guerre
civile
mais il ne fut qu'un pion entre les
mains des guises au cours de son règne
très bref
charles neuf voulait être un roi
guerrier comme son père mais ses
ambitions excédait ses possibilités
malheureusement il n'est connu que pour
avoir donné le feu vert au massacre de
la saint-barthélemy henri iii celui en
qui l'on fondait les plus grandes
espérances ne parvint pas non plus à
redresser la situation
sous son règne la monarchie se montra un
puissant son manque d'intelligence
politique contribue à alimenter
l'anarchie qui avait gagné bien au delà
de paris animé par la crainte il agi de
manière impulsive ce qui le conduisit à
sa paire catherine de médicis joie en
permanence un double jeu elle espérait
qu'en se montrant bienveillante envers
les forces antagonistes elle
parviendrait à réduire la fracture
religieuse à unifier son pays et à
renforcer la monarchie mais elle ne
pouvait savoir que la réforme
déclencherait autant de haine et de
violence ni que l'église irait à
l'encontre de tous ces efforts
d'apaisement ni enfin que ses fils ne
lui serait pas d'une
dans dead toutes ces stratégies ne
servir à rien face à la faiblesse dont
avait hérité ces garçons on peut
remarquer l'ironie du sort la dynastie
des valois avait accédé au trône
parce qu'aucun des trois fils de
philippe iv le bel abbés d'héritier mâle
et elle s'éteignit deux cent soixante
ans plus tard pour la même raison les
quatre fils d'henri deux disparaissent
sans héritier permettant ainsi à leurs
cousins bourbon de ceindre la couronne
royale la révolution avortée de 15 189
est un événement historique car il a vu
naître une conscience sociale qui va
mourir pendant deux siècles
c'est en effet deux cents ans plus tard
en 1789 qui éclatera la révolution
française
mais avant cela les bourbons vont suivre
les traces des valois et devenir à leur
tour rois de france